>> Sure. So once we built the code generator, we built a number of
supporting tools that were useful in just understanding these assemblies and
communicating them to to others. One of them is a graphical visualization tool
that'll let you, let you look at in graph form in a,
in a dot form. One of your assembly specs so that you can see exactly what
the dependencies are, how the different refinements compose with one another.
That's been really useful particularly as we were developing our [UNKNOWN] to
begin with, because we've found that over time we could compare these,
these different visualizations and we could see them getting simpler and
simpler. So that was very useful. We also did we implemented some code metrics,
so that we could track how large or small our refinements were.
We, we hypothesized and this actually born out to be true that over time and
after a lot of use, big refinements will break down into compositions
of smaller ones and in fact that's happened. And we use code metrics now to,
to help us find candidates that we should, should go
kind of proactively dive into. So yeah, there are a number of little tools and
supports like that, that are pretty useful.